what's up guys this is our first full
day in Venice I'm about to hop on this
little shuttle boat not a bus it's a
boat because we are indeed in Venice and
basically the only way to get around
here is by Velva I don't really know how
to feel about it I've been getting a
little bit of motion sickness recently
so here we go good luck to all parties
involved
away - come on I'll fight this alone
remaining
we'll start with name
gum was a request by our dear friend jg
and he said it you see it get it these
basically been sending us photos of this
gum every single day since we've been in
Europe better be good James yeah yeah
better Wow Batman there's some paper on
this one but oh really good food
shopping no room for shopping I think I
wanna kinda go in here okay
oh yeah what did we just see we all now
somehow I ended up with magic sunglasses
so this this turn up party just got even
more turned up he started off by saying
Rihanna has these and I was like I don't
care
but then I put them on I'm like alright
they're great these week I'm looking for
silver reflective sunglasses - you were
I was looking for something super subtle
that would be like you know not very
obnoxious well and this is what we came
for right now we came for do you think
you're real I feel I feel like it I know
it's like lightning strikes every time
juice
and everybody's watchin her but she's
thinking that you okay we're leaving now
let's go on our tour let's go to Brown
Oh baby
who's gonna get seasick first I think I
want to be okay
surprise feel fun you're right they'll
ever got anywhere yeah
vince moranto
who's a quite a long boat ride actually
over here we learned a few things today
Venice is made up of 117 connecting
pedestrian islands with 30 or so
surrounding it so the bridges basically
connect all 117 to make it walkable and
then the rest of the place you gotta
take a boat
apparently this place is famous for
Burano lace and it's a very beautiful
intricate detail they make 600 he is off
tradition generation to generation okay
she's one of the youngest Elise maker at
the moment here in Toronto this is so
incredible one of those little tiny
doilies can take up to three months and
seven different people are working on
one single item that's that blows my
mind I do not have that kind of
dedication to anything except making
YouTube videos
something that's really actually kind of
really sad is the woman in there who was
doing the lace stitching she's one of
the youngest people on the island that
does type of stitch that she does so
like people aren't doing this kind of
stuff anymore so the whole tradition of
creating these beautiful pieces is now
thought machines do everything not
complaining but it's still sad
we just got the biggest veronik biscuit
I've ever seen I think it might be the
first I've ever seen
let's go get that iced coffee and break
his biscuit open we've been wanting iced
coffee for a really long time and we
just learned you just have to ask for it
it's not something that's on the menu
but it's called it's called shikre Otto
I just wash my hands so I'll just dip it
in my coffee well that was like the best
iced coffee that I've ever had in my
entire life Viva Rosa we're thinking
about coming back here to get dinner or
lunch tomorrow because it was so good
now we're off to murano yes we're
running out time is changing date
we're about to head into a glass factory
as this is so awesome
everything's work so predict for you
just know you're not that someone who is
like my heart my life is happening
I don't wanna miss the letting go is she
dead broke and now I'm gonna tell you
why Brooke because he didn't put it
inside the kiln later I'm gonna explain
to you so right after one pieces finish
they have to bring it inside the kill
one and two go ahead go ahead
wow you're good go go
okay now hold the Beeson oh shoot
okay so the horse broke because they
have to put it in the kiln for over 24
hours for it to cool down slowly and now
there's air-conditioning in here and it
feels incredible so they're now leaving
this amazing glass factory they call it
a factory but it's not really like a
factory factory we were allowed to film
upstairs where all of the amazing pieces
are because they don't want them to be
like duplicated but I did buy this
incredible bracelet for now heading back
to the main island and probably get some
dinner as usual this place is so
beautiful I had such an amazing time
here
how can I reach you when you shut me out
why
I'm still inside
oh I love you and I have no doubt
the time
that's a shot look look
well what's gonna pop into the shot
Jennifer here check way down here Wow
basically all I wanted to say was our
dinner has been fantastic which is order
dessert and Jenna hit me in the face
well these desserts look fantastic I'm
loving life
sauce and dark and we're back where we
started this morning tomorrow maybe
doing a little Don Vila ride and who
knows what else
stay tuned for that scene the next video
we ran into madness
Oh what